[Music]  many rioplatense worry that they are at  a disadvantage to first-time applicants  is that true and do you have any advice  for people are trying to replay and we  really read them fresh so my best advice  is the person who is a value in your  application likely has never seen it  before so there's no reason to explain  what's different or what changed or  maybe why you think you didn't get in  some people try to tell us that just  start fresh and look at we've already  submitted you don't have to change  everything but think is there something  at this moment in time that could be  more compelling perhaps in the last or  some way I want to change it to be more  representative of where I am at this  moment but please do if you're committed  to Stanford reapply because there's um a  lot of students that we admit from that  category some of my favorite classmates  are really glad they're here that's  awesome